let's get to the phones which we do via
Discord on the Friday show
davidpackman.com
Discord join the Discord it's free it's
a good time
um but let's hear from some people at
davidpackman.com Discord see what is on
people's minds let's go first to Nelson
from Bethlehem Nelson welcome to the
David packman show
Nelson welcome to the program
oh I apologize David I had pushed to
talk on thank
you
um I actually just had one question and
I want to know if I can get your
thoughts on some breaking news sure
um what is your opinion on the United
States government uh taking out the
mandates today for the um
uh International Air Travel you don't
have to be covered vaccinated anymore
the U.S took that out for incoming
travelers from other countries
yes and federal employees and the such
no longer have to be covered vaccinated
I saw that and I was really surprised I
thought it was supposed to be a
permanent thing um uh I think the White
House put out a thing on it you can see
it I believe that it all ends on May
11th yeah let's see I've actually got it
here so we can be precise U.S covid-19
travel restrictions to be lifted May
11th will be the last day for multiple
restrictions including that
International Air visitors be fully
vaccinated listen I don't know what my
medical opinion on it is I can tell you
that politically I get why it's been
done why it is being done and I also you
know if we are to believe that at this
point in time the vaccine doesn't
prevent transmission
um then in a sense I get it right it's
sort of if you want to protect yourself
from becoming seriously ill you get
yourself vaccinated but if it doesn't
reduce transmission then why does
everybody need to be required to be
vaccinated I think the risk of it is in
an Ideal World Nelson
at some point we will have a coveted
vaccine that does prevent transmission
and at that point no longer having the
tool of requiring it could be a missed
opportunity to actually reduce
transmission of the virus but that's a
future looking question
yep oh well I completely agree David
well thank you for having me on First
and um shout out to my good friend soft
gentleman he's also listening but he
can't call in right now so thanks David
have a great day Nelson from Bethlehem
very powerful stuff
um what was that the soft something I
don't know what that is I don't know if
that's a listener of mine let's go next
to Will from North Carolina will from
North Carolina Welcome to the program
what's on your mind
hello uh I know that your focus is
largely electoral politics but I was
wondering if you have any comment on
them
some means of uh affecting Progressive
political change outside of electoralism
like maybe labor organizing or a mutual
Aid in your community just any thoughts
you have on that sure I think that if
all we're doing is voting and then
tuning out for four or two years that is
a huge missed opportunity and this is
unfortunately you know the right
understands this will that's the thing
the right understands we're going to
raise hell at school board meetings and
we're going to try to get involved in
Municipal uh uh requirements and you
know this recent idea of let's ban trans
people from dressing in line with their
gender identity that they're they're the
Department of Agriculture I guess in
Texas is trying to put that in place the
right knows how to get involved in all
of this other stuff and I think it's
critically important that the left do it
as well and whether it's again School
Board city councils
um events in communities all of these
things dealing with police policy right
get making yourself heard uh when there
is the possibility of changing police
policy within a municipality we've got
to be doing all of these things and
importantly you know Neil Postman wrote
about this okay we vote
and then we watch all this news about
Russia and Ukraine as interesting as it
is and as as important as what's going
on in Russia and Ukraine uh is in
affecting people's lives there
what are you or you are you going to do
about the situation in Russia Ukraine
and shouldn't we redirect some of the
time that we're focused on issues that
we will never impact shouldn't we
redirect some of that time on our local
communities so I'm with you a hundred
percent
all right well thank you David have a
great day all right will from North
Carolina great to hear from you